well the dugout store is very busy right
now as they're
making new
chris bryant jerseys
he will wear number 23.
ron woodis will switch uniforms and
he'll be wearing number eight
kevin gossman on the mound for the
giants fourth in the national league
with a 2.21 era a national league
all-star however he is scuffled of late
so now the astros have runners at the
corners with nobody out and yuli guriel
at the plate the o2 again and gurio
grounds it through the right side that's
a base hit altuve can walk home brantley
trots to second guriel drives in his
fourth run in the last two games and
it's one nothing astros
three straight hits to start the day
for the astros
and now it's kyle tucker's turn
here's the payoff pitch
that is outside ball four
and the astros lead two to nothing
brantley trots home tucker trots to
first
12th start of the season for valdez a
2.97 earned run average this year he'll
be facing the giants for the first time
in his career posey hitting 326 416 on
base percentage 13 homers and 31 runs
batted in the 1-1
and that is lined and caught by correa
diving to his left it was starting to
sink as it got out to carlos and he made
a nice adjustment it looked like that
ball was hooking as well
the pitcher from bervaldes will lead off
here in the second inning astros lead
two-nothing kevin gausman still in the
game and desperately goes without saying
needs a quicker inning
here in the second
two-nothing houston gosman
with the pitch and a swing and a miss he
threw a slider and struck him out altuve
is going to get booed every time he
comes up in this series i believe
two strike pitch is called strike three
got the call
a splitter at the knees two down that's
four strikeouts in a row for kevin
gausman
other than buster posey ruff has the
best numbers against lefties this year
the 2-2
and that is strike three call on the
inside corner and ruff goes down looking
so now the top of the order comes up
austin slater for the second look
at this astros lefty
right field base hit
estrada being waged home and he will
score without a play
stopping at second was gorsman
first hit of the game for the giants 2-1
houston
so now posey comes up for the second
time
two on one out
deep
left field line
and
right off the base of the wall
gorsman scores the tying run
slater stops at third and buster posey
down two strikes and nothing
has tied the game with a double
second and third and still only one out
for mike yastrimsky who grounded out to
first his first time here's a 2-2 swing
and a miss got him on the curve ball
and wilmer flores comes to the plate he
ground it out his first time
here's the 2-2
strike three call on the inside corner
frozen with the curve ball and the
inning is over but the giants send eight
men to the plate and tie the score
they strand a couple and after three
astros two
giants two so here comes aled miss diaz
and the pitch
swing line drive right center field and
yostremski on the run slides and makes
the catch
jumps up throws in towards second
back to the bag tucker
almost headed toward the gap in right
center but yes it was playing over in
that direction
it just wouldn't hit all that hard and
he was able to run it down with a nice
sliding catch
reaching his glove out
to the right
so one out tucker still at second and
here is martin maldonado the catcher
he struck out to end the first inning
leaving the bases loaded
two strikes to count gaussman ready
throws
fastball struck him out swinging again
chew down and here is the pitcher from
bear valdez who just had his first major
league at bat
leading off the second inning he struck
out swinging
0-2 pitch
struck it out swinging with the splitter
eight strikeouts in four innings
but gorsman one hit a lead-off double
and chucker never got past second base
and the giants have two on with one out
and gosman is going to hit for himself
2-2
and that's bunted foul so that's strike
three
and that is the second out of the inning
bunted it just to the left of home plate
so still two men on but now two out for
slater austin slater an rbi single in
the third to get the giants on the board
and grounded out his first time one for
two here it comes that's a ground ball
left side right at diaz he's up with it
and side arms to first low on a hop and
it pulls guriel no he stayed on the bag
he did come off but first base umpire
brian odora said he stayed on
before
coming off he stayed on long enough
jose altuve stands in against kevin
gausman one for two with a single under
run scored
now the 01.
and altuve hits it in the air deep to
left it sends back estrada at the wall
looking up see you later
jose altuve goes deep and the astros go
up three to two altuve's 24th of the
year
and here comes gloria one-two pitch
right there fastball at the knees
strikes recall
julio
strikes out looking and that's the ninth
strikeout for grossman
now it's mike yastrimsky's turn
left-handed hitter is over two a ground
out on a strikeout one of two
left-handed hitters in the lineup
tonight
now the 3-2
swing and a miss
got him on a fastball inside and that is
strikeout number six for fraumber two
out
kyle tucker leading it off for
the astros
swing live drive to center field coming
on and diving
slater makes the catch
altuve homer in the fifth to give the
astros their current lead he also has a
single and a run score two for three
the 2-2
and altuve hits it well and deep to
left-center going back as estrada at the
wall looking up grand slam jose altuve
his second homerun of the game
and the astros lead it 7-2
third grand slam of the year for jose
altuve
and he has driven in five tonight
tucker
led off the inning
there's a swing and a fly ball shallow
left center racing in the left fielder
estrada and he makes the grab here's
solano right-handed hitter 3-1 pitch
swing line drive fair pass third and
ricocheting on down the left field line
and hits you off the sidewall and goes
to the left the other alvarez
profit around third he scores
and it's a stand-up double for donovan
solano
duggar the pitch hitter for one two
strike three call on the outside corner
at the knees giants have two on with one
out
and darren ruff coming up here's the one
two it is hit high in the air to right
center field way up there
who's going to take it tucker will make
the call and he doesn't catch it
he dropped it
everybody advances the base the bases
are loaded
with wilmer flores coming up bases
loaded one out flores hits a high fly
ball left center field but not that deep
alvarez does not have a great arm and
he's fighting with it he'll make the
catch angling back at the last minute
cozy tags from third hill coming to
score so now crawford comes up against
stanic
crawford lines one into left field base
hit yasremski will come in to score
and it's a two run game seven to five
astros it is the astros debut
for kendall graveman donovan solano at
the plate the go ahead run he's two for
three with an rbi double the one two
from graveman ground ball up the middle
to his left correa he's got it
straightens up throws to first and it
goes
so guriel now at second base with
two outs for correa who was over two
with a couple of walks
breaking ball and that's lying down the
left field line that's a base hit and
that'll go all the way to the wall
curiel scores correa on his way to
second as he trots in with an rbi double
to make it eight to five astro
vlad miz diaz stands in he is one for
four with a single
kendall graven impressive in his astros
debut as diaz belts went deep to left
back goes dickerson at the wall looking
up see you later
ollenby's diaz goes deep and the astros
go up nine to five
fourth home run of the year for diaz
so now darren rough
base hit to right field
buster scores yaz will stop at third
donovan solano the last hope for san
francisco he is two for four with an rbi
double
lifted right center fairly deep going
back is brantley makes the catch two
steps from the warning track and that is
the ball game